Short and sweet number 16. We presented many different solutions for leaving wine unattended with a non-Jew.
The first solution was if the bottle of wine has a double seal, so once it has been double sealed, it may be left with a non-Jew unsupervised.
Ramosha told us that even a single seal, but that is almost impossible to replicate, would be considered a double seal and would protect the wine from being left unsupervised with a non-Jew.
We said that metal screw caps on a bottle would be considered a double seal because the moment that they are opened, the ring breaks off and the only way to reseal the bottle would be to bring it back to the factory, which is almost impossible, in which case it's also considered a double seal.
A cork with a foil wrapper around it is also considered a double seal. The cork alone in the bottle is just one seal. Some people actually held that it was a double seal because the cork breaks when it's opened and therefore it's also impossible to replicate.
Even those who did not agree held that a champagne cork would be considered a double seal because it is pretty much impossible to get back in once it has been taken out.
If a person needed to create a double seal, they can put the bottle of wine in a plastic bag and tie the plastic bag very tightly around the bottle,
put tape around the bag, which can tear very easily if it was tried to be removed,
and sign both the tape and the bag. That would be an effective double seal around the bottle.
Some opinions considered putting the cork so tightly in the bottle that it would need a tool to remove it as one seal.
And we also discussed the question of these new inventions of the caps with the combination lock.
So if it only has a three-digit code, there are those who say it is not a good double seal because it's possible to crack within a half an hour.
However, even those who are Machmir held that a four-digit code would be considered double seal because it would be very difficult for the non-Jew to crack the code.
And again, a four-digit code would for sure be a double seal. A three-digit code, according to some, is a double seal. According to some, it's not.
If a person, B'dievet, left a bottle with a non-Jew with only one seal, the Rama told us, for the Ashkenazim, the bottle is Muter B'dievet.
And the Aruch HaShulchan said that because non-Jews don't lie bait nowadays, it's even enough to have one seal on a bottle.
If a situation came up where a bottle was left with a non-Jew, but the circumstance is that the non-Jew knows that they are not allowed to touch the wine,
and on top of that they are afraid of getting caught touching the wine because they could lose their job, then the bottle would be permissible.
We introduced also the solution of Yosef and Echnas. That's where we have the possibility for a Jew to show up at any time unexpectedly, and the non-Jew would be caught off guard if they were trying to touch the bottle and a Jew could come in at any time.
So, in that situation, the non-Jew may be left with an open bottle of wine, again, assuming that they know that they're not allowed to touch it, and then they'd be afraid to do so because at any point a Jew can pop in without warning, that fear, that mirsos is enough to prevent them from doing so.
However, there are four requirements that are necessary to rely on Yosef and Ichnas.
The first one is that the non-Jew must think that the Jew can enter at any time.
The second one is that when the Jew returns, the door must be unlocked, or at least if it's locked, they can see through the door clearly to the bottle of wine.
The third requirement is that the non-Jew is not allowed to see the path that the Jew would take to get inside.
If they can see it, we assume that they know, and they have ample warning to protect themselves.
of wine. If a person was relying on Yetziv V'Nichas, and they
are lacking one of these requirements, and again, assuming that the non-Jew
is an idol worshiper or a Christian, or is a Christian, so then the bottle
and the barrel, if the bottle and barrel is open, so then the wine would be immediately
forbidden. We are concerned that they touched it and had
intent to libate. However, if the bottle or the barrel, which was left of the non-Jew, is closed
with a forgable seal, so then it's not forbidden immediately.
If a person has live cameras pointed at the wine, and the non-Jew knows that they are not allowed to touch the wine, and they at least have a strong suspicion or know that you will be watching those cameras frequently, most posts can consider it a heter of Yetziv Adichnas, and it would protect the wine.
wine. We lastly said that if a bottle of wine is hidden away in a place where it will not be able
to be found by a non-Jew, so then you could leave the non-Jew unsupervised in the house, and we are
not concerned that they have found the bottle and touched it as long as it is hidden very well.